joining us once again here on the Rich
Eisen show entering his seventh year in
the National Football League DeMarco
Murray how are you DeMarco I'm great how
are you ready for talking to you I'm
really high on your Tennessee Titans
right now what are the goals for this
team
I mean lay it out for me here DeMarco
I'm obviously our our goals were to get
better every day obviously you know I'm
just very early second week of preseason
I'm just finished up on our second day
with the Panthers and I'm just great
great two days work with those guys and
thought we got better as a offensive
unit special teams and defense and I
think our goals right now is just like
every other team you obviously you want
to win your division make the playoffs
and obviously vote for Lombardi but at
the same time we got to take one day at
a time and focus on us well being on a
team at you you were on a couple of
years ago where you were Dez Bryant
catch not a catch away from taking a big
step towards winning a Super Bowl how
does this team compare do you think yeah
I think we can very obviously long you
know rishard Matthews came along great
last year we got a really good receiving
depth Delaney's won best ideas and laid
off his line very similar to the one we
had in Dallas and obviously we were led
by number eight you know back there
quarterback a guy who I call him quiet
assassin you know he's a guy who has a
lot of hard has a lot of pride about you
know us as a team and I'm looking
forward to having to be here for what if
why'd he call him an assassin a quiet
assassin DeMarco because he is very
quiet what where's the assassin part is
quiet it's quiet I think the second part
is how he approaches the game on a daily
basis you know he doesn't say too much
easy so he's a pro you know for a 30
year guy to come in and work as hard as
he works on his craft and on this his
footwork and it's throwing most of
things like that on the officer has a
great coaching Jay Mike and he's the guy
who makes plays for us he makes plays
for when we need them he can run the
ball you know which was obviously a
great tool for us and put the ball on
the money wherever it needs to so when
you say hard worker can you give me an
example where you're you're you're
showing up he's already there or
something like that or you're looking
across the field you see something that
you don't normally see out of a
quarterback DeMarco oh yeah obviously
she's usually the first guy in here I'm
always something yeah I mean I give it
pretty early myself in Delaney and
obviously office llama he's he's always
beating us I was in training room can
treatment in a weight room don't what he
asked to do to get one W get loose and
um you know obviously when we take brace
tone practices over there with the
quarterbacks again throws in making sure
the time is right with the receivers and
things like that so he has a great work
ethic DeMarco Murray joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show what can we expect
with you and Derek Henry in terms of
carries how's that split going to go
this year do you think I let my coaches
worry about that on for me you know I
was always you know obviously them
started here and I pride myself on doing
more than just run the ball you know I
pride myself on past rotation and being
able to run on the backfield and you
know catch some balls so for me uh
doesn't really matter to me I'm focused
on the obviously winning and obviously
you want to be out there make as many
places you can't pray team but I'll let
my coaches figure that out well have the
coaches talk to you about it I mean is
that the way it works essentially we're
like okay DeMarco we're going to put you
in these situations and Derek we're
going to work you in these situations no
no I don't think we run that way
obviously you know I mean I think for us
you know it's um similar to actually you
know obviously we're both going at the
ball we're both gonna have our times
I'll get on the field on the big for me
it's just all about you know just taking
one play at a time you know and if in2
tired eagles here and gives me and tom
and he sees a get our young running back
and he'll play in this league for a long
time and i you know for us I think it's
it's great we're both here on the same
team well in our draft coverage Steve
Smith on the NFL Network said that Corey
Davis reminded him of Terrell Owens what
say you um you know Cory Cory sir he's a
very talented guy another guy who
doesn't say much guys as a young guy you
know you expect those guys would be kind
of loud and little obnoxious you know
especially on having you know being
being drafted so high but he's a guy
that were excited about these missed a
couple time you know sometimes with the
hamstring but hopefully he's coming back
in there in the time being and now I'm
just he's working hard to get back out
there but he's a guy that definitely can
go looking at the ball run very terrific
routes and we're excited to have him I
gotta be honest with you DeMarco when
you said guys you know like that loud
and obnoxious I thought you were just
going to save wide receivers
there's a feeling out there there's a
feel I'm just glad we don't have them on
our team okay because you know I thought
you're about to paint all wide receivers
with that broad brush DeMarco
no no not right now okay next round okay
it's interesting I say that Corey's a
guy who doesn't do a lot of talking and
Mario does a guy doesn't do a lot of
talking and your guy doesn't do very
much talking either it's odd that you
all play for a coach who does so much
talking in Mike Mularkey DeMarco okay I
mean oh you know you did volcko so I
think it deserves a talk whenever you
want to and definitely I'm glad that he
has to do it a lot more than we have to
tailor the lawn and drill Casey Delaney
those are kind of the talkers on our
team so we live upstairs I'm through all
that but they're great they're great
players great people come on is give me
a good malarkey story did he cut the rug
does he cut up does what it will give me
good one what's your best Michael a
large block Torrey funny guy he likes to
play some jokes every now and yes he
thinks he's a lot funnier than what he
has I'll give him that
laughter obviously a lot because he's a
head Ball Coach
but I'm some of his jokes aren't too
funny okay so he's he does cut it up
because it looks like he's just playing
I mean he looks like he's a straight man
if I had to figure it out DeMarco I
would say ninety ninety percent of time
is really no other 10% he'll crack a
joke with you but that's the thing about
him you know he's a players coaches guy
who expects a lot from us and we
understand I would pro so he wants to
know every direction you know no matter
walk through game lifting traveling he
wants us to be pros at all times he
wants us to he'll be focused and
mentally sharp at all times so we get
that to trickle down there you know from
him to the coaches to know every player
on this roster I got to tell you I'm
looking to your first four games the
first one against Oakland that could be
huge
I mean home-field advantage of for a
playoff game could be on the line later
on in the season for something like that
you're at Jacksonville where the Jaguars
are going to try and feel the ropes in
their home opener then your home for
Seattle at the Houston Texans DeMarco
those are very important statement games
for you and I know the whole one game at
a time situation but approaching those
games
do you feel like these are all measure
up games for your team right off the bat
oh yeah of course you know of course
obstacles Aram I think two two of those
teams you know I mean you know Oakland
and in shadowy had offices in synthesis
for last couple years Oakland is that a
great run the last couple years and you
know in our division you should has
wanted the last coverage Asheville has
making big big splashes all season with
a and you know they got us in week you
know arm sixteen months last year so
it's obviously you know a tough schedule
you know we're excited by we're excited
about the challenge and our main focus
is to take it one game at a time you
know you try not to look down the road
but the definitely can look past Oakland
Raiders so we're excited to have them
come here to Nashville and we'll see
what happens okay and you're from Vegas
the fact that the Raiders are heading
there do you think that's going to work
out what do you think also also the
people are you know well stationed other
obviously they've been burning for a
team for quite some time and finally got
one next year and hopefully they do well
but not this year or the next year but
I'm aside that obviously I'm from Vegas
born and raised I love it I still you
know consider that my home my family
still lives there so you know I know
that the city is very very ecstatic
about you know the Raiders moving there
do you have a take on McGregor
Mayweather going down to Vegas coming up
in 90 days you know what I'm a big UFC
guy great friends with Dana and I'm
Lorenzo obviously is out of it now but
you know I wouldn't say you know I don't
know I don't know what's going to happen
is definitely interesting
I'm excited definitely gonna watch the
fight I wish I can go but it's going to
be tough obviously for the Vegas guy and
I'm friends with Dana and the rest of
those guys up there so I'm just hoping
for a great fight and but it definitely
will be tough hmm so you're thinking I'm
trying to you know you got you got a lot
of allegiances there it sounds like you
know it's hard to bet against obviously
Mayweather when he's I don't know 49 and
oh whatever the case may be and then
Gregor's coming in there from the
obviously age of striker he's a warrior
the one thing you can't put a pass in as
you know he's going to fight is going to
apply to the very end so it was
definitely going to be interesting were
you surprised by Bob Stoops stepping
down
at your alma mater DeMarco I was a
little bit you know obviously you know
when you think about only thing you know
big game Bob and I was fortunate to play
there in special time and have a great
relationship with him you know even
after I was done there and I'm he's a
wonderful man from top to bottom
great football coach you know great
father husband and I'm a god to
definitely talk to you you know that
importance of life and not just football
so for me you know it was on it was a
little saddened I was a little saddened
by but I think everything every good
thing comes to an end at some point and
I think there are set aside about on you
know link Reilly in Norman so hopefully
bring these things or some more Victoria
Championships and some national
championships yeah in terms of good
things all good things come to an end
obviously you're staying Dallas a few
years ago did what did you think of all
the Hall of Fame hoopla for Jerry Jones
DiMarco you know I had a great four
years a you know one thing about Jerry
is a family oriented man and you know I
was able to witness that firsthand no
not just him but you know his entire men
the Thai Joe's family know they treat
you like family you know and you know he
deserves me he deserves everything he is
received and obviously he's definitely
worthy of the you know Hall of Fame so
it was great to see him great to listen
to a speech I thought he did a great job
now I got it I got to say this I'm just
looking at the first week one schedule
and I'm looking at the games on CBS I
don't know where he's going to wind up
but Oakland Raiders at Tennessee Titans
has to be the spot essentially I would
put my a team and I think Tony Romo is
going to be in that booth what is that
going to be like strolling into a
broadcasters meeting and seeing Tony
Romo sitting there DiMarco you know
these would be funny
hopefully my guys at the game and then
call me game he's going to great at the
job and it would be great obviously it's
going to be a little weird and I know
he'll try to get a lot more information
out of me than anyone else laughter
maybe text him and love no off the
record or something but he's a great guy
very very well-liked and I'm excited to
you know see is Sam in the future yeah I
think he's going to do great at it I
really do did you think at the time when
you're playing with him that he wanted
to do this um no I figured he would I
think it I thought of
would be that or coaching obviously
knows a game inside now he's a very
well-spoken guy and we took a family
vacation
after the season that shared to
bora-bora his wife and my wife and I and
a couple other couples and that's when
he first told me before he announced it
I was like holy crap man Congrats you
know obviously I didn't think he would
retire I thought he'd still want to play
and just speediest he's a you know he's
very competitive so I know he's been
working hard at it and I know he'll do a
fine job at it so what's it like going
on vacation with Tony and and it's and
his family are they are they are they a
couple that's on time do they keep
everybody waiting tell me what's it like
going on vacation with that I will say
he's always on time um he definitely was
a very generous guy obviously and the
one thing about it that I guess the only
negative is he controls the Bose speaker
he doesn't allow people to play any type
of music but himself so my chest when
you are what when I'm bored bored I mean
I guess anytime within me he's the one
who wants to control the music so I
allowed for the most part those
quarterbacks to control freaks man they
really are was it at least acceptable
music selection at least all the times
you know he comes with some great hits
you know I'm every now and then I'm
about 10 minutes it gets a little boring
and I know maybe budge them or a little
bit 11 la I'm gonna take over if he
doesn't change it so then he you
actually back up a little bit he calls
an audible I think very good take care
of yourself DeMarco great chat with you
we'll chat with you down the line always
a pleasure thank you always that's at
DeMarco Murray on Twitter so Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show app
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show